um let's bring you some more breaking
news regarding these fixed penalty
notices that are being issued by the
metropolitan police the prime minister's
wife carrie johnson has received one a
spokesperson for mrs johnson said this
in the interest of transparency mrs
johnson can confirm that she has been
notified that she will receive a fixed
penalty notice she has not yet received
any further details about the nature of
the fpn of course those receiving these
fpns don't know
what parties they're for what dates etc
etc so that's the details they're
referring to there let's bring in our
chief political correspondent john craig
who is in westminster so over 50 fpm's
now issued by the metropolitan police
we've got the prime minister the
chancellor and the prime minister's wife
involved well the prime minister i will
no doubt say that uh it's a home of both
uh mr johnson and indeed mrs johnson and
their very young children uh but uh this
uh news has come pretty swiftly from
carrie johnson
she is said to have organized as i
recall the birthday party for the prime
minister i think in the cabinet room
it's known that she has attended some of
the gatherings there and i suppose given
that the prime minister
has been going to be issued with a fixed
penalty notice um it's perhaps no
surprise that his wife also who is uh
nearly always at his side uh obviously
in downing street is also being uh being
uh fined uh she's moved pretty swiftly
to set the record straight here as
you've just said in the interest of
transparency
um some people might say she's been more
transparent than her husband and other
figures in downing street she can
confirm she's been notified she will
receive a fixed penalty notice she
doesn't know any uh details yet about
the nature uh just let me bring you a
little bit more reaction nicholas
sturgeon has also said that
that
that boris johnson must resign he broke
the law repeatedly lied to parliament
the basic values of integrity and
decency essential to the proper working
of any parliamentary democracy demand
that he should go should take his out of
touch chancellor with him
so
political opponents are up piling in as
you can imagine i come back to the point
i do think it's worth considering the
position of rishi sunak here
because uh as we've been discussing he
has had a torrid few weeks and there
have been suggestions that he might be
ready to walk you'll recall that the at
the weekend removal vans turned up in
downing street
and uh a lot of furniture was moved out
of the chancellor's flat now the
explanation we were given was that uh
rishi sunak's multi-million uh wife
was moving out with their children it
was claimed temporarily to their to move
to their home in west london to be near
their eldest daughter's school so
clearly some upheaval in the uh sunak
household already it was reported that
he'd been considering resigning over the
whole uh
tax problems he and his wife are facing
remember he gave that defiance and at
times emotional interview to the sun
towards the end of the la last week and
hit out at those who were criticizing
his wife and he's saying don't smear my
wife so the chancellor
uh if not the prime minister and we know
the prime minister will want to cling on
but the chancellor it has to be said
is more likely to quit than the prime
minister and if the chancellor were to
resign if he were to say i've had enough
of this
i've been found to break and lock down
rules and i'm facing all these questions
about my tax affairs i've had enough i'm
going to quit um then of course that
really will massively pile the pressure
on the prime minister if the chancellor
were to resign